بيخلق من الشبه اربعين مبابي النسخه
المصريه للوهله الاولى تعتقد انه كيليان
امبابه بسبب الشبه الكبير سواء باللون
البشره وشكل الجسم او الملامح حيث ظهر شاب
مصري في مقطع فيديو تداوله رواد مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي يشبه لاعب المنتخب
الفرنسي ما ادى لتجمهر عدد كبير من
الاشخاص حوله في قطر للالتقاط الصور معه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ربنا
[موسيقى]
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي قيام عضو مجلس
الشورى السابق العماني احمد البرواني
بتقديم عرض النجم الارجنتيني ميسي بمليون
دولار مقابل البشت الذي رفع به كاس العالم
كما زاد الاقبال الكبير على محلات البيع
لشراء البشت العربي بعد ما ارتداه ميسي
حيث يشاهد سوق واقف في العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه اقبالا كبيرا من مشجعي الارجنتين
وبلدان اخرى على شرائه حيث حرصوا على
التعارف على صناعته وطريقه لبسه
[موسيقى]
انتشر مقطع فيديو مروع من داخل طائره
امريكيه تعرضت لمطبات هوائيه خلفت عشرات
الاصابات كانت في طريقها لمدينه فينكس
الامريكيه وكشفت السلطات في هواي عن اصابه
نحو 30 راكبا بجروح والبعض منهم في حاله
خطره
[موسيقى]
خطفت الجزائريه فايزه العماري الاضواء
واستحودت على اهتمام رواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في الاونه الاخيره حتى تصدر
اسمها محركات البحث
التي تحمل الجنسيتين الفرنسيه والجزائريه
الاسلاميه
لكره اليد كما مثلت فرنسا في بطولات
اوروبيه واليوم تدير اعماله ومصيره اغلى
اللاعبين في العالم
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم